[Applaudissements]
magnifique cette belle entrée en salle a
damé thuram abîme quoi en temps
on y gagne je suis votre est ce soir
[Rires]
teva regarde y sera ainsi obligé j'adore
sa présence qu'il ait eu et je suis fou
de toi assez gentil merci il faut le
libérer plus tôt du coup
n'est pas débordé
mais ça c'est fait partie des gens qui
sont payés à rien [ __ ] dans la avec ce
remake on aime bien ce qui arrive je
risque d'être libéré pour toujours ah
ouais oui non on commence tout de suite
comme chaque semaine ce que vous savez
que j'ai une petite fille là je regarde
tout ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
pendant les magnétos eh bien j'ai réuni
tout ça dans une séquence ça s'appelle
la gazette des offres tout simplement et
c'est parti
et on commence avec vous cyril alors
tendez bien l'oreille on est quand même
sur un animateur qui n'a besoin de
personne de personnes pour sur un
tel sujet
on continue avec hugo man of tai a voulu
sortir ça lance avec un pompier qui
était invitée cette semaine mais échec
cuisant pour ce bel éphèbe
[Musique]
il était au musée d'orsay mais d'abord
il était à gaza des choix avec et après
il était
[Musique]
et c'est le retour des anecdotes téloche
de bonnes mains 4chan j ai regardé sur
l'île qui sent mal et toujours autant et
doit
maintenant j'ai pas de gp2
je vais attraper par le bas côté
[Musique]
de ces femmes très compliqué si là il
s'est trouvé un nouveau tâche manquerait
jacente terme qui fait
comment lui dise non
à la toile à 3,15 ou pas j'ai un mec
toile gémeaux
[Applaudissements]
sanogo
au revoir
ça irait mieux canet c'est bon
maintenant série ne s'occupe de rien
yann danis a banni de sa nouvelle arme
est elle
assez bonne qualité de cyril
c'est pas sur moi je pense que le marché
croit je pense simplement pas ah oui
même si c'est je crois pas du tout
on est à l'antenne
avec des chronos
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
by you
any size plus d'affaiblir désolé j'avais
pas dit ça je la dis que j'ai appris à
quoi j'avais dit angie a pris un coup
vinh long et un très long
mais c'est mon patron
j'espère je suis pas ton pote
il ne serait pas la meilleure tomber
quoi là
[Rires]
mais
c'est carrément la plus calme je ne tire
aussi
les parties à l'accord prix ils
partirent tuquoi un pain un pantalon à
pinces et
fait serveur ce genre même
nom mais seriez vous allez y va pépère
va sortir de sa moitié que j'aime
beaucoup
le système bien avec j'adore j'adore
c'est mon pote c'est ma couille
la niche qu'est ce que tu me lui réponde
un truc baffe
il ressemble pas trop à kenge je pense
qu'ils ressemblent pour toi cyril c'est
vrai ah ouais mais il est très beau il
est très bas maintenant
attendons mais c'est vrai que ouais on
dirait le fils de sacha et de cyril
ouais
ouais ouais
bien manger un peu tu gueules nana qui
dorment ils dénoncent également les très
beaux oui les très beaux tient cette
semaine personne il a beaucoup de
charisme exactement soit 6 à la
tromperie d'anissa comme avant je suis
désolé nice a
été toujours avec ta meuf vous avez une
question c'est avec ta meuf oui je suis
toujours avec ma meuf oui en effet
anissa ça pourrait que ton style sacha
ou pas baca costa repêché en couple non
mais souhaitant mais imaginons qu'ils ne
soient pas en couple ah oui oui
c'est pas celle de quelqu'un
il est mignon je sais qu'il est debout
là
[Applaudissements]
pas ça drôle à noter très beau nom mais
l'armée
s'était tu es célibataire est ce que tu
aurais pu non je pense pas
tunis afp n'était pas je sais pas c'est
pas trop beau si les célibataires ton
style ouais c'est vrai
[Rires]
guillaume bio
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec ton mec
pourtant il n'a pas du tout le même
style
baby g et non l'une à
dîner un peu trop vieux pour sa mère
et daniel
beaucoup si mathieu teychenne très bonne
émission
autour de sept sont les chroniqueurs les
plus dissipés à mon avis c'est mathieu
mathieu delormeau
et benhaim
bringer les votes
pas content extraits bah oui c'est
mathieu et aymen ayari bema les deux
c'est vraiment charles et dino pendant
les pubs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
ses
[Musique]
traditions qui est toujours très sympa
avec nous et qui est parti et toujours
du bien de des émissions et de moi
partout il nourrit toujours des petits
des petites à qui vous aviez qu'est ce
qu'il a dit quoi tpf et c'est vulgaire
non non il a dit là c'était bien
bon et pas on n'est pas la couleur des
tractions
la butte pour mon père une meilleure
tête
[Musique]
6-4
mais dites moi ne soit pas tout le temps
à 100% c'est faire beaucoup d'émissions
non mais tu vois
puis lundi une vidéo une escort girl se
tait
déféqué sur le visage pour plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de routes du
soufisme en est allé tout de suite
bayh avait 2,7 me la principale
destination des matières dans les
actuelles
notre qui venu en histoire c'est
évidemment ici on se rencontre et on va
voir régis vatan régis est accusé
d'avoir participé à cette émission juste
pour faire
la grosse chômage celui-ci c'est avant
tout grâce à american idiot les rage
avec thé comme tout le monde
valérie l'écouté parce qu'il y va
toujours là pour vous défendre merci
c'est cela c'est des vrais la phrase là
qu'elles soient pas toujours à 100% oui
j'ai pas dit béni non ça c'est vrai
c'est bon c'est vrai mais je veux dire à
tous ouais je vous ai donné beaucoup de
conseils de beauté bref je me suis
beaucoup ouais mais
non mais ça je sors tu peux votre coach
ah c'est vrai j'ai des gaules hayden
ouais c'est vrai un lait comme j'ai
décollé à sané est plus que décoller
franchement et samedi les noms de
revisiter prime time quoi tu en orbite
un prêt
bon bien là dessus
que je fais lancement cyril lundi la
france a tremblé un événement eu lieu
dans le monde médiatico politico sportif
par classement au passage la wii un
événement que les téléspectateurs ont pu
suivre lors d'une fête que vous avez
célébré un perso brement ne fait tout
simple à votre image cheryl mais figurez
vous que
je suis pas nous l'état parmi 10
mai un événement a eu lieu dans cet
événement un coup de foudre ça les
téléspectateurs ne l'ont pas juge ce
coup de foudre s'appelle christophe
regarder magnéto et on emporte tout
après
le classement ensemble
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas nul hein christophe christophe
chanut s'allume très beau c'est pas nul
a figuré vous que ceux qui n'offrent pas
de taper dans l'oeil et pas que dans
l'oeil à quelqu'un autour de cette table
de quelqu'un
de quelqu'un les papiers de rec 2
quelqu'un oui mais de qui à mon avis a
gagné
trois fois qu'il a tapé dans l'oeil
ninja doute voilà tu es salaam
accabler la pareille aux gars
là où la halle à l'aller il montera
scénique et la ligne nord chat tu vas
être
jamais
l'espoir iv qui peut conduire une
porsche un jour mon petit bonhomme
scénique faudra que je sois pas toute ma
vie en scénic aubin restons scénique des
jeunes à
balagny ça tu comprends ce qu'ils
gagnent hissel te regardes tu
as compris la conversation ou pas tu
mets coup de rein par ch
à faire
un bon choix
pour les
[Rires]
recruteurs de taper dans la ferme et à
prague est maintenant je reviens
bande-annonce est encore pire elle va
chez léon c'est pareil cd fait tout seul
ah ouais iberia
mais aussi à les regarder on regarde
[Musique]
les habitants
alors
c'est tout
mais et c'est fini et et
nouvelle-zélande
non mais c'est hyper je ne savais pas
combien de vitamines b celle de l'amour
siri vous le savez à rien et donc
pourquoi remettre au lendemain ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui figurez-vous que
christophe même habillée c'est à plèbe
un vrai plaide christophe
[Applaudissements]
s'ajoutent les cordes daniel sesma tapé
dans l'oeil oui non peut jouer
j'adore les fruits et légumes
vous avez 500 km ou encore parler n'a
pas bien vu mais c'est un petit peu
quand même trop bien sûr c'était rapide
et platonique vous êtes mais on a quand
même quelque chose savaient que je
l'avais déjà vu quelque part ça ça oui
c'est vrai que disait quelque chose
on voit pas bien donc je peux te fait
quoi
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé proche non
mais c'est vrai que je me suis senti
tout de suite à l'aise oui moi aussi
série
intéressante c'est pas que la nudité
c'est aussi chez ba feeling que
peut-être sept jeux voilà le sourire je
suis enchantée voilà vous êtes
célibataire
[Applaudissements]
alors souhaitons j'ai dit que
c'est pour moi que ça va être difficile
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais là en plus dans ces séries est
magnifique c'est quoi dans la vie
christophe serveurs non non non non non
je suis agent immobilier ça n'a rien à
voir leur nom à lyon n'ont même pas
aussi un peu ça se rejoint quelqu'un
dont je
voulais faire une petite danse à daniel
oui je veux justement je trouve le flou
enfin moi c'est des souvenirs d'enfance
mais j'ai l'impression qu'à la saison
voilà j'avais envie de sénat
comme bâle comme aux balles quand on
n'est qu'à la saison
les boucholeurs
la saison
mr juvénile rg la natation ça n'arrive
pas le temps de
s'attarder pas si vous mettez de la
musique on danse et on m'a laissé coi
d'accord
pas vraiment
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est vrai
à la plagne est une femme très bien aux
femmes
il sait parler aux jets privés ça reste
entre nous personne ne nous avait aussi
tourné le compliment il m'a dit que même
de près j'avais toujours cette saison
non je n'ai pas dans le haut niveau
c'est vrai que là
il s'est bougé merci grand lille bouge
encore vivant mais attention
chose qui m'a j'ai eu l'impression que
c'était pas totalement platonique non
plus et que vous faites vous pouvez
aller impôts de la chine mais est ce que
je peux faire une déclaration
bien sûr oui c'est cela la ration de la
déclaration de jacques d'amours
[Applaudissements]
sur cette
séquence
[Applaudissements]